how's it going everyone this
International master Danny wrench
this is chest comms YouTube channel and
today we have another installment for
our chess openings playlist here again
you can find probably just about every
opening you would ever imagine you could
play even in your wildest dreams you
will find that in our YouTube channel a
list so go ahead and check that out the
last installment was on the AL open
Sicilian which is a very common and
popular anti Sicilian goes a little
something like this with c3 trying to
support d4 so that white doesn't have to
concede anything in the center when
challenging blacks control the main
description of the idea is behind that
approach are in the previous video and
then the chess openings plays so I hope
you guys check that out so today we're
sort of looking at the next most logical
step as far as openings go it's also an
anti Sicilian and it makes sense because
we also play C 3 but these two openings
are far from far from similar with the
ala pin slowing down White's development
in order to try to support a potential
positional advantage the Smith Moore
gambit as you see the title here after
the move d4 is an opening designed to
accelerate White's development at the
cost of sacrificing even material in the
center after d4 black is going to take
it and they're pretty much if you're a
black player playing the Sicilian here
you don't really have any option but to
capture on d4 once white challenges
because the space advantage itself is
simply too much to try and ignore moves
like d6 would just run into me capturing
and maybe trading Queens and destroying
your Kings right to castle for the rest
of the game and nothing else really make
sense so if you're really a beginner
player just trying to take the time to
explain the basic philosophy again and I
talked a lot about the basic philosophy
behind the Sicilian and the reasons
behind the alop in Sicilian in the last
video so sort of get a bigger picture
you can again check out that one but
after d4 black is obviously taking it
and if you were intending on playing
just a regular open Sicilian would have
made a lot more sense to play Knight of
3 and move to before d4 as now capturing
with the Queen instead of the knight per
se as if it was developed would simply
run into a loss of time after Knight to
c6 and any logical move here including
Knight f6 or perhaps even she said
they all look pretty good for black as
white is you simply downtime having
wasted a couple moves here with the
Queenie Pooh so that's not a good idea
so logically we end up here with the
Smith Moore gambit especially if white
plays to d4 and what exactly is the idea
well white is is making a sacrifice of
two pawns on the Queen side to open up
lines for the pieces in this situation
the C file is now open the D file is now
completely open White has one move lead
of one move lead in development with the
knight already being on c3 and also very
active and open possibilities for the
pieces of the bishop on c1 obviously has
options to head to f/4 or g5 this Bishop
will likely go to c4 though it even has
other options white is getting a
development advantage in compensation
for the pawn but but the basic
philosophy there is is as it is in every
gambit you sacrifice something to get
something and so if the compensation
doesn't work out then you may simply
find yourself down material from mice
perspective but potentially it can work
out extremely well and some of the most
beautiful attacks have been conducted
from the Smith Moore gambit and one of
the games that we're going to highlight
and show today will show you kind of the
other pros of playing this opening I'm
going to give my suggestions as far as
the cons as well but we're going to want
to try to do all that pretty quickly
here Black has a number of moves here
the move played in the game we're going
to be reviewing is the move Knight to c6
which is probably the most logical
developing move and as long as black is
is emphasizing a few critical points
whenever you're playing against again
but he should be okay nice e6 is not my
favorite move I have a specific line
that I like to play against the Smith
Mora but the main point and points and
tips I'm going to offer for players who
worry about facing these types of
dangerous gambit so that whenever you're
up material your idea needs to quickly
become what do I need to do to equalize
the other factors in the game right so
if you're up material you already have
one advantage but what did you what did
your opponent get in compensation for
that is it a development lead is it you
know my king side is slightly weaker is
it you know a trapped piece or a
sidelined piece kind of out of the play
like taking the making the critical
thinking skill effort to establish what
it is your opponent is getting in
compensation for that material and
prioritizing
solving that weakness and fixing it ASAP
is really the number one thing you can
do as far as critical thinking skills go
so regardless of the theory I'm going to
show you when you're playing against any
gambit remember your opponent gets
compensation for the pawn you've won so
immediately recognize what that
compensation is and try to emphasize
will recognize what the best way is to
equalize those other factors in the
position and again it's just a basic
logical thinking process to have in
terms of your approach and even if you
don't know theory that will help you
against the Smith more particularly you
need to highlight or think about it from
the perspective of Kings side before
Queen side I typically think that blacks
should try to develop his King side as
quickly as possible and get out of the
center in order to avoid potential
problems against the king and even
strong grandmasters who don't do that
can really feel the wrath against
White's development like the game we're
going to see but quickly let me show you
some other things about this with Morris
so after Knight to c6 Knight to f3 one
common mistake a lot of players make is
trying to develop this Bishop on on c8
after Bishop c4 they bring the bishop
out to g4 which pins this knight that's
going to run into some serious issues
after Bishop takes f7 check 90 g5 check
winning the bishop with the discovery
right that's ouch town Bishop g4 is a
common idea that that black looks to do
when they're not really thinking about
their development as far as a bigger
picture they're not looking at their
opponent's threats and so this is a move
you really want to avoid playing against
before I've made that mistake you did in
my earlier days often actually so that
wouldn't be a good thing
typically what black actually tries to
do is instead of playing d6 actually
tries to play ecigs and a6 in a lot of
positions c6 have being a move that
blocks off White's Bishop scope a6 being
a move the guards to be 5 square because
whenever you play e6 your d6 square
might become weak potentially with that
said the line that I recommend playing
for black is a move that starts with e6
and a six and then actually d6
completely neglecting the development of
the Queen side for now trying to take
away some of white's critical squares in
the center the access the white gets
there and the approach of trying to
bring this knife from a seven to g6
which is a is a square for the knight
that actually go
earns a critical dark square in the
center rather than being a target to
potential tactics on on e5 eventually we
can't dive too deep into the theory in
this particular video lecture but there
is more information in a recent member
analysis video actually on the other
site and roman shinji house really has
also covered this variation in some
videos so if you want to go check those
out in any case after Bishop c4 d6 the
main point is the black is neglecting
this development and going for King's
side before Queen side which is a big
piece of advice I have whenever you're
playing against canvas so I would say
that you could look into that line if
you want but again in this main game
after Knight to c6 Knight f3 and II six
white played Bishop c4 anyway a six
again is played taking away the b v
square we have castles 97 this is sort
of a line that's very similar to the one
i recommended with the development of
this knight being different than the
standard knight f6 development yes it
takes an extra move so sort of breaking
the Kings side before Queen side in a
hurry but you're doing so because you
really recognize how much better the
knight is placed on g6 one that guards
potentially important squares rather
than like I said being a target to
potentially really powerful attacking
ideas from white so this is a really
interesting development and I think that
this approach is actually not a bad one
for black even though it really didn't
work out well in the game mr. Marquez
Fuhrman playing the white pieces
International Master a friend of mine
who is maybe one of the world's leading
experts on the Smith Morgana but no Gio
was playing against Grandmaster lokva
and weally from the Netherlands and it
got ugly here really quick after Bishop
g5 which is a common way to try to
induce a problem with ninety seven even
though you're losing a tempo after f6 as
we've learned we know that pesky cannot
return to their home once they once they
push so this so this guy is going to
regret weakening the King later on after
Knight to g6 Bishop to b3 kind of a
prophylactic move that avoids tempos
from the pawn but also opens up some
tactical chances for the pieces getting
out of the way the C file and other
things one of the main points here is
that I know that mark just from knowing
in person he was very well prepared in
this position and actually had a
specific move prepared after the move b5
and this game is as good of a stem game
as good of an ideal I
dia as far as how white should be trying
to execute whenever you play a Smith for
gambit as any game I've ever seen even
only being international master doesn't
really matter he takes down one of the
strongest teams in the world and like I
said he's very well prepared so this
idea is a very common tactical motif it
takes advantage of blacks King being in
the center and it shows you why even
strong grandmasters really need to
emphasize a really solid and
well-prepared approach against the Smith
Morra
the move is Knight to d5 exclaim a
beyotch bam in your face threatening
something pretty simple I'm going to
trap the Queenie pool on d8 and after
each takes d5 each takes d5 black at
first seems to be pretty happy given the
fact that he's up a piece but we're
going to see that White's mr. s Ehrman's
preparation did not really stop there
and recognizing should be that this
Knight really doesn't have any other
good squares going back or even 2a5
moves that don't block the e-file will
have other issues and so black seems to
be playing the right approach with nice
cd5 but after d6 Bishop to b7 White has
another really strong idea that if you
want to pause the video and see how Mark
approach this position quickly exposing
the King pretty much for all time in
space from here on out go ahead and if
you have in Polish your video that's a
you problem okay I guess you don't care
about getting better at chess no I'm
kidding but let's move on Knight takes
e5 F takes e5 Knight takes e5 would also
allow other things again including
kicking the knight out of the square and
either using tactics on the e-file or
even on this diagonal will leave the
King pretty much stranded and fresh meat
for the white pieces after xx d 5 F for
opening up the F while this was the key
idea and I think at this point White's
attack is already completely
overwhelming after Queen f6 F takes e5
Queen takes e5 a double X clam move one
of the one of the most creative and fun
ideas I've seen in a long time was
played in this position thinking about
how to expose the King in the center
Bishop to g5 BAM really really strong
idea and points out that not only am i
opening up the e-file but I sort of have
a crisscross pattern going on your King
right now and my bishop isn't even
capturable here if you want to pause
your video and see why you can the main
point is that taking the bishop doesn't
really relieve that blacks problems
after a move like Queen de
one check either you block 27 with a
piece and give me back some of the
material I've sacrificed pretty quickly
after Bishop f7 check taking with check
and the attack rages on and if you block
on e5 with a piece pretty pretty seems
like a pretty slick idea I have Bishop
f7 check Queen a5 check using the entire
board and we finished with a forced
checkmate on c7 so you can take a look
at this at home with your own computer
analysis engine if you want but whites
attack is is pretty much out of control
at this point
hence the reason why I've and really
tried to give back some of the cheer of
Bishop e7 but after Bishop of 7 check
taking with check material is is now
even again for for all practical
purposes blacks only extra material
being a pawn with obviously not nearly
enough compensation to justify the Kings
the King's mating net position white
plays a number of forced moves to kind
of finish off the attack Bishop f4
threatens Queen to d6 and lights out
Queen takes f7 Queen to d6 King tries to
run back you can pause and try to finish
off the game if you want but SMN played
rook takes c6 and took with the Queen
the rook is trapped so best-case
scenario black is going to be down a
piece worst-case scenario he'll probably
be made it before heave it has time to
think about being down a piece and this
is like I said an ideal stem game to
have memorized if you're somebody
looking for a really dangerous anti
Sicilian as far as your approach to want
to Black's main weapon so again it gets
a really well-prepared opponent upon his
opponent no matter where you live in a
sacrifice of material with a
well-prepared approach is is always a
risk but you saw it from this game that
even strong grandmasters who can think
they have a welp approach can run into
real issues and the tactics in this myth
more give white a really fun and
exciting game and like I said even
though the move c3 is played before move
5 in both the Smith Morgana and the ala
pan they couldn't really be any more
different with the album being a slower
positional approach on this fifth more
being is about as in your faces you can
have as far as an anti Sicilian so I
hope you guys are enjoying the chess
openings play this hope you're getting
all the information you need and I will
hopefully see you around on chess calm